yes bullying we have a major i-team
report ready to go when you say this I'm
ready to go right now for an
investigation the motto of our news team
is we don't break news we sprayed it
let's go to the newsroom point moment
set for the Super Bowl Seaton Fritzi and
I were walking out Seaton was in front
of me I was behind him Fritzi behind me
Seaton bumps into someone I see him out
of the corner of my eye and says a quick
hello and they turns around and the next
day I know Seaton a little salt he goes
you see what just happened like yeah you
said I had some Tigers Josh Altman for
million dollar listing just blew me off
and now on the phone Dan is good friend
of the show Josh Altman million dollar
listing led to response hey big time
what's happening yeah hey Jon I have an
explanation I'm sitting in front of my
computer and a Google Alert pops up and
I see you guys talking about me and not
such a good way so I have to say my
piece
okay okay go ahead you got your rebuttal
all right here we go okay it's -5 out
all right I'm in Minnesota my Patriots
born and raised Newton boy Boston
Massachusetts they lose clearly I'm not
in a good mood okay nobody in that
stadium who's a Patriots fan is in a
good mood I am always very nice and take
pictures with everybody I'm trying to
figure out how to beat the crowd out of
the stadium so I don't have to walk
outside and the -5 degrees so I'm
rushing around with my brother all I
hear is the lava Dan Patrick so I'm
thinking it's one of your fans Dan so I
turn around say hey and I keep walking I
had no idea was one of your guys
otherwise I would have stopped give him
a million-dollar hug and even spoken to
him for two to three more seconds and
then I would have ran seaton you want to
have a chance to rebut the rebuttal no
no it's fine all of that makes sense I
mean it wasn't negative five in the
stadium but I do understand trying to
beat the rush of the crowd and I've put
in my place no problem totally
understand that sometimes you can't
address big time stars in those moments
why does it gosh why is it
Oh Tom Brady's wife had more time to say
a load of people after losing including
Philadelphia Eagle players and you
didn't have time to say hello to little
seat no Connor all right let me ask you
guys were there did you did you walk in
the sky walk afterward oh dude it was it
took like yeah no joke it took about 45
minutes just to get out of the stadium
it was hell
right that so that's what I was trying
to avoid because I knew otherwise I
would have gone outside my blood is
super saiyan now that I've been in LA I
can't survive in that type of weather so
it was really a do-or-die moment so we
can turn it around and see he was
actually trying to kill me by stopping
me how painful was that loss it was you
know what look it was super painful the
the Eagles deserved it it is what it is
but it was painful especially when you
fly in and you experience the whole
weekend and you're expecting what you've
done the last couple of times you've
gone to the Super Bowl it just hurts it
hurts
seaton is he absorbed here are you okay
I mean for a guy who makes deals like
that I'm surprised there's all these
excuses but it's okay it's all right
like josh is used to lying you know
because he's in real estate he's like
you know I'm sorry that I didn't get
that house for you but you know it was
cold out and then traffic and I just
couldn't stop it sounds like he's moved
on Josh I think I think seems pretty
good now Seaton has said that Josh Flagg
would never have blown him off but Josh
Altman
Flags your man Albans too busy yeah yeah
yeah you know got the baby by the way
how's your daughter the daughters
amazing ten months old next time any you
guys are out in LA dinner on me I love
you guys you know that are you sure all
the time I like are you sure yeah okay
let's make time because we just recorded
that it'll be on tape and we're gonna
play it over and over and over every
time you blow us off in Los Angeles okay
I love you guys I gotta go back in the
chimp I'll talk to you later
z-man skipping like they have it it's a
Josh Altman former kicker he did have
one of the great videos that was awesome
back he and his brother I think are both
kickers and he got out of a car
he had his suit on and and then he had a
Syracuse shirt that he put on Jersey on
and then he kicked a field goal and his
first try for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]